- He's a professional
football player who plays for
Real Madrid and the
Portuguese national team.
He's the first player to win four European
Golden Shoe awards.
He became the world's
most expensive player
when he moved from Manchester United to
Real Madrid in 2009.
He's Cristiano Ronaldo and here are his
top 10 rules for success.
- [Cristiano] Everyone in
my family love football.
Well I remember I was always
playing in the street.
One day my father coming
and he said to me,
"Why you don't coming for the club when I
"when I work?
I say, "Yes why not?"
And I start to play to the same routine
and I start I go to every day to training
and I like it, to be part of a team.
And I'm training every day and
my father was there to help me.
Well in the beginning I feel that I have
I was different than the other kids.
Yes, I feel.
But I didn't even thinking
that one day I will be
a professional and playing for example
in Manchester United around (mumbling).
Even in sporting.
I just play you know to enjoy.
But I'm never thinking
that's hey, I have talents
and I'm going to be a professional.
In the beginning I didn't feel that.
(upbeat music)
- [Announcer] Way from the
beginning and he shoots.
A second goal.
Another one for Ronaldo.
He's invincible here.
(upbeat music)
- This is very important for me.
I'm always competitive player.
And not just in the games, I'm (mumbling)
I'm like that in a home with my sisters
and my mom with my nephews.
I'm always try to competitive
hard and try to win.
I'm like that, no I'm not
I'm not I never change.
And because I like I like
this I like what I do,
I like my life, I'm happy person.
So competing is part of my life.
So in Madeira and Madrid
in England I was all into
this competitive person.
So it's part of me.
(upbeat music)
- [Announcer] Relationship
is not existent with
a (mumbling) Ronaldo!
(upbeat music)
Manchester United (mumbling)
- Why make the move from Manchester United
to Real Madrid?
- I think everything
have a beginning and end.
And everything.
So what I I do what I did in Manchester
is completely finished
because I win almost everything there.
So I always try for a new challenge.
This is why I try to do
to move Manchester for Madrid
not about the the contract.
Is about new challenge, my family too,
close to my family.
Different weather, the language
everything.
And most the most important
things what I move
is a challenge
because I really like to put myself
in a pressure to see
what I can can can do.
(upbeat music)
The first thing and the
most important thing for me
it's it's football of course.
Nothing above that.
Well of course this kind
of stuff I like it too.
Something that I was
involved many many years
since I was 18.
So it's something that
I like it but of course
my my first focus is
of course the football
but fashion is something
that I like it too.
(upbeat music)
(foreign language)
- [Announcer] Ronaldo!
- [Cristiano] The people
really don't know you.
Who is the people to
judge something that they
don't know?
Of course this is it's
something that I don't like
but I have to live with that.
I cannot change, cannot
change my personality,
can cannot change my character.
I cannot change my education you know.
I respect the people but
of course I don't agree
because the real people who know me
know who is Cristiano.
You understand?
So I cannot change the
mind of the other people.
Maybe sometimes in the
pitch I show something
that the people don't don't
want or don't like but this is my my
kind of way to to thinking because I'm
ambition person and I don't smile a lot
in the pitch because
I I try to be focused.
But in this in one point I will
understand some people because you know
in a life love always
the people who judge us.
But I think sometimes this
is not fair but you know
we have to live with that.
(upbeat music)
- [Announcer] Oh my word!
Can you believe the genius of this man?
What a hit.
David James stood like a statue.
- [Cristiano] You have to work.
I tried to do it almost every day
this is why I'm in the
top level many many years.
I think it's not it's not my confidence
it's a because I do it extra
outside the pitch.
When I'm 12-years-old
most of the people told me, Cristiano
you are very very good talented player
but you are very skinny, very slim.
And I put it in my mind
the body we can improve.
We can improve you go to gym.
Dedication and hard work.
You can improve.
So I will improve myself.
Athleticism means a lot.
For me I think the small details in hand
are going to make a huge
difference to compare
with with the other players so I think
it's very important to
do this kind of work.
And I think it's going well on me
this is why I'm in good shape
almost all the year.
And I want to carry on
like that because it's
helped me a lot.
It's part of me.
I'm not doing that kind
of work because I have to
it's because it's part of me.
(gentle music)
- [Announcer] Watch a goal
from Cristiano Ronaldo.
Ronaldo!
(cheering)
- The question.
(foreign language)
(upbeat music)
- [Announcer] And he shoots.
A second goal.
A second goal for Ronaldo.
That was a hit.
(upbeat music)
- [Woman] Record matches?
- [Man] Nothing, zero.
I just try to do my best every season to
win the the Golden Boot.
It's it's important for
me, it's my second one.
And it's something that
I look forward for that.
I continue to say thank
you to my teammates
because they they helped
me a lot they give me great
passes to score goals.
But is you know
what I say a few interviews before
I will change the on personal things
for collective wars like champions
or La Liga because it's
the most important.
But in terms of individual I
think I play very very good
this season and really
really happy with what I did.
(crowd chanting)
(upbeat music)
- [Announcer] The
relationship does not exist
(mumbling) Ronaldo!
Brilliant!
(upbeat music)
Cristiano Ronaldo.
- Believe and follow his dreams.
Work hard.
Many many important
people and people who are
expect a lot especially
my my dad and my mom
always give me you should
you should respect.
If you want respect you should
respect the other people.
And this is what always putting in my mind
if you see my my career at
the last six seven years
I am always a kind of similar
level.
Why?
As I said before is a long process
is a dedication, it's hard work.
And for the future
I will try to maintain the same.
I'm going to I'm going to push myself
until my body and give me
good answer.
So this is why I'm enjoying the present
and I don't think a lot about the future
because I know the
future will be good too.
But I just enjoyed the
moments, I feel good,
my body's good, just
maybe the best moments
of my career so far.
And I want to continue it.
(upbeat music)
(foreign language)
- [Announcer] Ronaldo!
(pop music)
(foreign language)
(upbeat music)
- [Announcer] Here he comes.
Oh my word!
Can you believe the genius of this man?
What a hit!
David James stood like a statue.
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
Marlo Acosta asked me to.
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave
it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which
of Cristiano Ronaldo's
top ten rules meant the most to you.
Leave it in the comments and
I'll join in the discussion.
Thank you so much for
watching continue to believe
and I'll see you soon.